bruno le maire a annoncé cet après midi
et bien que les géants du numérique
notamment amazon devaient prendre leurs
responsabilités pour ne pas faire ce
black friday
cette fête à des promotions est ce que
il est assez ferme bruno le maire je
suis pas sûr qu'en parlant au coeur
d'amazon il va obtenir un résultat
parce que demandé au géant comme vous
les appelez du numérique de reporter le
black friday s'est passé les ponts sur
quand même beaucoup d'argent et je suis
pas sûr qu'ils acceptent ça serait
beaucoup mieux que le gouvernement
permette aux commerces de réouvrir avant
le 1er décembre qui semble une date
promise d'ouverture et que dès le 27 on
puisse permettre celles et ceux qui
vendent et qui sont en grande difficulté
de pouvoir devancé ce black friday le
gouvernement n'a pas l'air très à
l'écouté sur cette date du 27 novembre
qui est demandé c'est dommage parce que
comme l'a dit sylvie vermeillet avec sa
question à l'instant à bruno le maire on
est en train de tuer le petit commerce
on est le petit commerce était en grande
difficulté c'est une année difficile il
y avait déjà eu le premier semestre
je pense que d'ici l'année prochaine ce
qui survivront seront des héros
[Musique]